one of the things that concerns me most
about where around society is
the sort of socialism communism
you know entrepreneurship is bad
technology is bad
and polarization of wealth and you know
people getting rich is a bad thing when
i grew up i'm 50 now
but when i was a gen xer growing up we
kind of maybe too much idolized bill
gates and people who are doing
interesting things in the world
and we thought capitalism was a force
for good i still believe capitalism
is a force for good because when a group
of people builds a product or service
that changes the world and it gets
globally distributed whether it's
tesla or spacex or google or airbnb or
uber or robinhood
you know everybody gets to benefit from
that product or service
having to compete and if you look at the
places where there's no competition like
public education or less you know
perfect you know uh
you know established you know colleges
and stuff like that less
competition for accreditation degrees
like things tend to get a little weird
don't they
yeah um and people tend to be protected
and that's not good you need
you need competition um does it mean
that
you know people shouldn't have global
health care it doesn't mean that you
know we shouldn't have a safety net but
we need to keep capitalism vibrant
especially because china
has now co-opted capitalism and created
their own version of capitalism
which is communism with capitalism it's
like this weird operating system like
we still want to keep communism so we
can take any of your gains at any time
yes but we'd like you to be
entrepreneurial yeah and then you have
somebody like
you know um you know the founder of
alibaba jack ma
who disappears for a couple of weeks uh
who's that
exactly like who's jack he kind of
disappears for a couple of weeks and
then he comes back and he's really sorry
about the things he said and
then he disappears again and like you
know we have to be very careful if china
wins
capitalism yeah this is going to be an
existential threat
for humanity yeah the chinese are no
joke
i mean they are seriously focused um and
they are picking the winners
it's a very weird system because it is
in fact i don't know what you call it
like communism capitalism in such
uh overloaded terms but they do
encourage entrepreneurship
but they and they do a good job of it oh
yes but but then they're like
they're like the surveillance thing and
they're controlling things in a way
it's weird because it seems to work
really well
for them uh in the short term yes it's
definitely got short-term benefits
so the question is like what what uh how
that gets distorted and
becomes worse and much worse which
should potentially might be
and i i think on you know
the the entrepreneurial spirit which you
have
a podcast all centered around the
entrepreneurial spirit
is one of the magical things that makes
this country great i don't know if money
is deeply tied into that
i do get bothered by people you know
treating the word billionaires if it's a
bad word yeah
but in general like all the hard things
all the difficult things we're going
through in this country it seems like
the way out is going to be uh
making the the entrepreneur the hero of
society
of like letting that young kid with the
big dream
and the guts to take the big risks and
build something totally new
uh make giving them a chance and
whatever that
involves i i don't think it's about
taxes i don't think it's about like
uh regulation all that stuff it's about
us and just public discourse saying
that that kid that guy that girl their
their badasses
like encourage them to do it we have to
have people buy
in to the fact that they have that
opportunity
and i think one of the problems in
society is there's a group of people who
actually don't believe
that they can succeed or they don't
believe even more perniciously
that other people can and that's the
group of people that i think are
highly vocal but a small group of people
which are
generally people of incredible privilege
rich parents
white city dwellers liberals they kind
of look and say poor people cannot
change
a lot and they're they're battling in
their minds
to protect poor people and but they have
this very weird patriarchal kind of
approach to it which is
they think that they're not capable of
changing their lot in life and they're
like
it's not possible and then once in a
while i'll tweet something where i say
you know it's really incredible that
every piece of knowledge you could
possibly want is now available for free
on youtube
and every course from mit and harvard
and stanford is available on edx or
coursera
and all that information is there freely
available and you can take the lectures
this is amazing and then people will be
like yeah but people don't have access
to it i'm like
they do it's free here's the link and
they're like
yeah but they don't have internet and
i'm like here's the chart of internet
penetration in america like
and they're like well poor people don't
have internet and i'm like really
find me any downtrodden person without a
smartphone
with a high speed connection that
capitalism provided
for 12 a month or 15 a month like it's
very hard to find that
and we have it so well in this country
and there's so much opportunity
um but people don't believe it and
that's actually one of the problems the
average american still watches four or
five hours of television a day
you